all right so Total Recall was the go 290
Sci-Fi Action Movie from my childhood as
someone who grew up with only like four
TV channels well we we got a fifth in
like 1997 but that's neither here nor
there catching this for the first time
while staying at my grandparents was a
treat sure I had watched Arnie in
Predator and Terminator 2 by this time
but after becoming a huge Star Wars fan
when the original trilogy had its
re-release Total Recall felt like Star
Wars meets the more action-packed adult
movies from Schwarzenegger and there was
a topless three-titted woman so 10 year
old Jared you know he he liked this one
but it was always one I never fully
understood like the more I thought about
the series of events and the ending the
more it confused me was Quade real was
how was it real did Benny actually have
five kids either way we're diving into
this 90s gem because re-watching it
really allowed me to pick up on some of
the foreshadowing just thrown in your
face it is everywhere but also the
technical behind the scenes side of
things was honestly groundbreaking for
the time so join me grab a spacesuit and
get your ass
kicking things off the opening scene on
the red surface of Mars captures that
Wonder of an epic sci-fi adventure and
then the sheer horror of space once
Quaid's mask breaks on the Rock I don't
know about you but this scared the
bejesus out of me as a kid sure we know
that this isn't how the vacuum of space
actually works but man the Practical
effects of Quaid's eyes and tongue
swelling were so well done this sets the
stage for Quaid's crazy Adventures as he
wakes up back in reality with his wife
played by Sharon Stone right off the bat
obviously after several re-watches I
never caught her nagging suspicion here
the look in her eyes asking if it was
the mysterious woman again was always
the first sign of confusion for me
whether or not this was Quaid's reality
I don't want to get too ahead of myself
on this front but some interesting
behind the scenes material is the fact
that apparently Schwarzenegger did not
like Stone while filming this movie or
at least at first no Rhyme or Reason
Stone just caught wind of this and was a
little bit more aggressive let's say in
their fight scenes even kind of punching
him here or there as a clear sign of
this now Quaid's dream paints a picture
of what he thinks Mars is this Serene
wonderful Planet but in reality it's
more like a war-torn third world country
according to the newscast that he
catches in the morning again showing
that his dreams and reality couldn't be
further apart on the same newscast they
mention turbanium and I'm pretty sure
that they bring this up or it's
mentioned a handful of other times
throughout this movie being the driving
motivation for kohagen to be terrorizing
the citizens of Mars so I looked it up
nothing except it's been compared to
unobtanium from the Avatar franchise in
that it's a high value export and
returns immense profits with the aura
essentially being used in the war
efforts back on Earth so uh we we both
learned something here but like I
mentioned up front there is a lot of
foreshadowing in this the first bit kind
of being the Mars dream to open the
movie but things really start to roll
before Quaid heads off to work I feel
like it was meant for something more
than this
I want to do something with my life I
want to be somebody
Quaid heading off to work taking the
subway looks fairly realistic right well
this was actually the real Mexico City
subway public transportation station it
was already built like this like a
futuristic looking location with them
obviously you know adding the X-ray wall
in post but the only other things that
they had to actually change were the
signs from Spanish to English some
metallic looking paint on the train cars
the original ones were like a bright
looking orange and then the TV screens
on the subway to have a more kind of
Ultra Modern feel this in turn saved
them loads of money because well at the
time this was one of the most expensive
films ever made budgeted at 65 million
dollars this was a huge movie for the
time sure in the era of James Cameron
spending a bajillion dollars on Avatar
films this looks like chump change in
comparison but nah Total Recall was a
huge gamble at the time it also ushered
in a huge increase for male lead after
its release and probably where budgets
and Hollywood salaries are now extra
staring into the camera and ladies and
gentlemen we got them
the X-ray machine was groundbreaking
technology and I'm not being sarcastic
this was one of the first Blockbusters
to use CGI and have it look
photorealistic it was difficult
expensive time consuming not great even
here the software that they intended to
use for these x-ray sequences just
didn't work the computers weren't
powerful enough so the animators had to
animate these couple of scenes by hand
using live action film sequences as
reference just mind-boggling once again
some foreshadowing with the recall ad on
the subway screens featuring Dr Edgemore
we will see later also it's a quick
thing if you notice in the ad they use a
butterfly as their kind of logo which
actually symbolizes transformation and
hope which Quade goes through after
going to recall surprisingly Arnold
wasn't originally going to play Quade
because of his hulking physique or at
least the original producer didn't want
him to this is because total recall was
based on Philip K dicks we can remember
it for you Wholesale in which Quaid or
rather Douglas quail in the source
material is an average frumpy
stereotypical office worker obviously
Arnold looks like he eats office workers
but through the years of the project not
getting off the ground he pulled some
magical Switcheroo work which was able
to secure the rights and then bring on
director Paul verhoven who he wanted to
work with because of Robocop Quaid then
changed the character to a big old
construction worker and boom problem
solved Arnold also added that a man of
his stature then losing his mind would
be one of the scariest things because
he's just helpless finally we get the
movie rolling with a recall Quaid
despite every single person telling him
not to go yet he still goes now Quaid
uses a similar looking directory
terminal as the one from die hard when
McLean checks into the hotel it goes one
further though as the recall salesman
then he's meeting with his last name is
McLean so it's all like connected man
Die Hard 2 even has the same propeller
prop seen in venusville so I'm saying
it's the same universe this is where
things start to really move for the
story and again I mentioned some
foreshadowing here or there this is in
your fish foreshadowing for the rest of
the movie right after McLean shows Quaid
the graph of how safe recall procedures
are which apparently shows that space
shuttle flights have become more and
more dangerous over the years which is
odd but McLean continues by saying you
got lost luggage lousy weather Crooked
taxi drivers of which all of this
happens to Quade during his trip to Mars
later most importantly Benny the taxi
driver McLean then tries to upsell Quaid
on the secret agent ego trip version of
his vacation and even though he says he
won't spoil anything he goes on to
literally spoil the rest of the movie
but you rest assured by the time the
trip is over you get the girl kill the
bad guys and save the entire planet now
sure it's vague and the first time you
watch this you wouldn't have a clue that
this is going to happen but yeah McLean
saying all of this gives a lot of
evidence to quade's trip being all in
his head rather than happening in the
bounds of reality now up until this
point this has all been reality at least
according to director verhoven but
depending on your view of Quaid's
Adventure which I'll talk about in a
little bit this is where things split
off from the reality to dream or fake
reality into real reality uh the recall
technician that works with Quaid is Dr
Lil meaning Lil or to calm or to sleep
or to be put to sleep here which is
exactly what she does after Gathering
some information from Quaid the
foreshadowing continues as concept art
of the alien reactor from the end of the
film is shown on the recall screen the
ideal mate Quaid has in mind turns out
to be Molina and when Dr LOL hands the
computer chip to Ernie attorney that's a
new one blue sky online blue skies on
Mars I mean come on the last bit of
dialogue that really makes me think that
this is later just a dream in his mind
is that Ernie adding he's going to have
a wild time he won't want to come back
this is where the movie takes a drastic
turn as Quade now thinks it he is Hauser
and his cover has been blown because of
recall again we'll touch on whether or
not this is true later but one
interesting thing is McLean purposely
uses Dr Lowell's first name in this
scene Renata which means rebirth which
is why Quaid is a completely different
person now and Harry and his boys treat
him as so even Quay doesn't believe his
new set of skills per se after taking
out all of them in an oh geez this has
escalated way too much Panic afterwards
okay okay so for the rest of the video
I'm just going to assume or talk in the
fact that this is a dream the whole
secret agent trip is in Kuwait's mind
because there's just far too much
evidence that is hinted or spelled out
to be you know just pure coincidence
obviously I'll trickle in evidence to
support this as it comes up and you can
hit that like And subscribe button and
also let us know your thoughts on
whether or not Quade is in reality
alright so everyone is after Quaid now
agency goons his wife tries to kill him
funny enough I didn't catch this until
this re-watch pure coincidence I'm sure
but Jurassic Park feels like it took
some influence from this scene with both
Arnold's outfit looking similar to Dr
Sadler's and also this iconic line
[Music]
clever girl
just something random I noticed but
Quaid escapes into the subway station
and again we see the first CGI work and
that honestly probably ushered in
Hollywood Blockbusters that we see today
with verhoven directing this in 1987's
Robocop violence would be in full force
no surprise total recalls original cut
received an NC-17 rating not because of
any sexual content here or there but
yeah basically it was just even more
violent than what we get here I mean
this escalator scene of Quaid escaping
and then just using this guy as a human
shield Harry and the Goon fight and
rector's arms being severed later in the
film had to be cut edited or censored to
actually bring the rating down to a
rated R which it ended with my favorite
part in any movie ever is said by
Michael ironside's Richter that's now
and an hour he could have total recall
that there it is there it is you can see
all of these advertisements in the
background and these are real ones that
were in Mexico City at the time verhoven
thought that they looked cool so they
just stayed in the film Quaid now
escapes to the Hotel Ritz which is
furthest thing from ritzy and randomly
gets a call from an old buddy from the
agency he leaves him a suitcase and
heads up again I always thought that
this was dumb luck coincidence but now
it adds to that dream storyline of
coincidence right place right time this
is all happening in his mind the old
woman who tries to fight and take the
suitcase from Quaid this is actually a
fun nod to Schwarzenegger in the first
Terminator movie
[__] you you [__]
[__] you [__] the secret agent ego
trip continues with Quaid narrowly
escaping kohagen's goon squad and then
the Johnny cab explodes out of nowhere
much like your stereotypical cliched
action movie adding to the secret agent
trip because it's an electric car I'm
pretty sure Quaid gets some clarity if
we're gonna call it that from the
objects in the briefcase specifically
the large iPad screen recording of
himself sure there are a bunch of random
IDs Martian money and even a brief
glance at the large Woman costume Quaid
uses later the wristwatch hologram that
shows off the more realistic
experimental CGI but is Alter Ego Hauser
is the main focus here basically laying
out how Quaid and him are the same and
kohagen did in fact get the two men into
this pickle it's weird because he
already knows everything that's
happening and is more than just a
recording honestly feels like it has
like previous reported responses which I
never thought about anyway comes one of
the gnarliest scenes Quaid having to
pull a ping pong ball tracking device
out of his nose I can't even imagine but
this and other concept designed
specifically the Martian mutants and
cuato where the idea of weird body
sci-fi Master himself David Cronenberg
knowing this you definitely see the
influences of his work in this movie but
Cronenberg was attached to direct this
early on in the production cycle however
as mentioned earlier things on this were
drawn out shifting ideas scripts
producers so due to this Cronenberg
unfortunately left the project but this
was all a Happy series of events because
he went on to replace Robert bearman on
the iconic 1986 the fly remix so I'd say
that this all worked out for the better
Quaid is caught up to by the goons
sabotages his equipment and heads off to
Mars but the famous repeating line tips
us off to where things are going get
your ass to Mars I would get your ass to
Moss I'm gonna get your ass to Mars
surprisingly this scene and fade
transition was a complete afterthought
because of budget constraints verhoven
mentioned he originally wanted a whole
sequence of Quaid aborting the shuttle
flying to Mars The Whole Nine Yards but
all of this ended up being much easier
with the fade transition because you
know of monies now once we get to Mars
there are some really neat exterior
shots of the facilities that were built
for colonizing the planet this was all
modeled after photographs of Mars
geography that NASA collected via
satellite which was then used as a
reference of course with the buildings
and other details being built for
Miniatures now Total Recall oddly enough
was like this weird abridging point in
effects with it being one of the first
to use CGI while one of the last to
utilize the wide use of miniature sets
almost an evolution in filmmaking in of
itself mentioning the blend of CGI
impact tactical effects is the two weeks
Quade in a woman disguise scene
obviously iconic and been parodied
several times the idea that Quaid hands
to the Customs officer does in fact have
Priscilla Allen's signature the actress
playing this part but the transition of
her freaking out to Quaid taking off the
outfit and then throwing that severed
head is maybe the best quick change use
of all of these differing effects at
work here oh also stop it here and
notice that the Mars soldiers have
calculators taped to their wrist to make
things more
futuristic while riding the train Quaid
asked about the mines and we hear about
the alien artifacts once again alluding
to the alien artifacts that the workers
at recall had said that they were
dabbling in it's a sign but one
interesting thing is the mountain mine
location it's looming in the background
of a couple of shots and is reminiscent
of the Mount Rushmore scenes being in
the background of North by Northwest
even similar window paneling between the
dinner scene and the few times that it's
shown here now a theory all of this is a
clear sign this is a dream because
recall needs inspiration for its dreams
right where you can go what's the best
way to draw inspiration older popular
media so recall modeled this setting
after the North by Northwest Mount
Rushmore scene the movie is also an
every man turned spy movie which is a
mirror of Quaid's Adventure so I mean it
can't just be coincidence more close
steer Quade to venusville specifically
his own handwriting telling him to ask
for Molina also I'm an idiot but I just
noticed this on the rewatch that Benny
was a kohagen plant from the beginning I
just thought that he turned later on in
the story but uh him constantly hanging
around waiting for Quaid like a personal
chauffeur it's far too sus before
meeting Molina of course every three
teenager's favorite scene was the three
breasted mutant Lady of the night a
memorable scene I'll say that it was
redone in the 2012 remake amongst other
media but actress Leisha enough says
that the entire experience portraying
this character was embarrassing and
depressing there are stories of her
breaking down after the scenes cut and
later declined guesting on Johnny Carson
and entertainment tonight so a kind of a
sad note to take things but we finally
meet the fabled Molina who just so
happens to be the same woman recall
picked for Quaid earlier on and again
another sign that this is all a dream
now fun fact Tony this freaky looking
dude is played by Dean Morris AKA Hank
from Breaking Bad he took his mineral
Obsession all the way to the Mars source
I understood that reference the meeting
between Molina and Quaid spells out a
bit more about their relationship and
how she only remembers him as Hauser not
Quaid so things obviously get a little
messy or really messy with him being
Quaid but she only remembers him as
Hauser because according to kohagen it's
assumed that Hauser was a bad guy
working for him I don't know everything
is all over the place but if we take a
look at Molina's earrings they closely
resemble the Martian pyramid minds and
the pieces dangling below are the
reactor cores that they use later hint
hint which brings us to the doctor Edge
more Scene the blatant in your face
Quade you are dreaming scene that I
think divides viewers into thinking this
is actually a dream or not again I
believe that this is a dream and
Edgemoor only provides more evidence to
this Theory first off him saying that
he's from recall is correct his name is
seen on the recalled directory and he's
also in their commercials but him
mentioning he's not really there is also
true symbolized by the way him and
Quaid's reflection show in the mirror
yes it shows Quaid may have two
different sides to his life but
purposely framing it so Edgemoor is not
reflected gives a nod to him being
implanted in to prevent Quaid from being
lobotomized I feel like Christopher
Nolan grabbed inspiration for inceptions
Mr Charles scene from this scene because
both entirely show their hand say they
are there to help in order to ease the
dreamer pretty cool but also much like
others Edgemore goes on to foreshadow or
I guess blatantly spoil the third Act of
the movie one minute you'll be the
savior of the Rebel cause and the next
thing you know you'll be cohagen's bosom
buddy fantasies about alien
civilizations as you requested but in
the end back on Earth you'll be
lobotomized so so if we take this into
consideration Quaid will be lobotomized
by recall at the end of the movie
apparently verhoven wanted to base the
Edgemoor character on the professor in
Alfred Hitchcock's torn curtain
basically he wanted to cast the role as
someone naive a bit strange a little
weird and I'd say that the actor Roy
Brock Smith nailed this also the Matrix
took the red pill blue pill idea from
this scene right the take the red pill
you wake up back and recall back into
reality therefore he doesn't take the
red pill and remains in the
computer-generated world or rather the
secret agent ego trip dream this could
all tie back to the colored nails of the
recall receptionist when Quaid First
shows up symbolizing this moment but uh
things honestly things get too messy if
we're even gonna talk about that so
Quaid headshots Edge more and all of
what he said was in fact true as this
scene of them talking is slow lower
halting the pace of the film but
instantly after his death a wall is
blasted up like him mentioning the walls
of reality come crashing down and the
secret agent ego trip is now Quaid's
perceived reality Quaid is captured this
is the end of it but Molina saves the
day and kicks ass against Lori who
begrudgingly is on Mars because of this
old Quaid debacle now Molina and Lori go
at it and according to verhoven he
didn't want to choreograph the fight
between the two like a generic cat fight
scene in you know countless other movies
but instead imagine these two as
warriors fighting one another
incorporating some martial arts moves
showing off their skills to feel natural
which was different Quaid ends his
relationship with Lori shooting her
saying consider that a divorce now
apparently the line was originally
considered this a divorce and then Quaid
follows through with the shot but was
considered two in line with a
cold-blooded murderer which just was not
the tone that they were going for at
this point with Quaid once again super
convenient timing by Benny driving them
back to the last resort escaping into
the old Martian tunnel system now with
this all being a futuristic Tech in this
undisclosed future I just never actually
knew when this was supposed to be set
but according to the cover art or cover
of the VHS Edition Total Recall takes
place in 2084. verhoven later confirmed
in the audio commentary for the film
mentioning that Blade Runner was a
futuristic movie that unfortunately was
too advanced for the time period that it
was set being 2019 I mean we don't have
any of that stuff so in doing so
verhoven picked 2084 and he better be
right because at an old age I'm gonna
need recall kohagen follows the typical
bad guy Trope turning off the air to the
Martian people leading to Quay Aid and
his meeting with cuato to be essentially
their last move the cuato scenes again
have that Cronenberg Flair to him gross
slimy but really effective in the mutant
psychic mutations they allude to earlier
the Practical effects on the cuato
puppet are insane because it took 15
puppeteers to control this little dude
burhoven later said that the effects
were so good for Marshall Bell and
Quanto that people would stop him on the
street and ask if he was actually a real
freak referring to Marshall Bell or some
sort of mutated Siamese twin which is so
weird to think about because obviously
you know this is a movie but at the time
this was groundbreaking once cuato is
able to open Quaid's mind the visions of
the Mars reactors are finally revealed
again they were hinted at by the recall
people when Quade was going through
orientation looking very similar to the
real ones now according to verhoven the
designs for the reactor were supposed to
feel like they were physically in a
nuclear reactor these giant
skyscraper-like poles going into the
Mars ice melting them however all of the
concept art that they came up with just
did not crack this design and I kid you
not apparently The Story Goes that
verhoven randomly looked at the designs
upside down when they fell on the floor
and boom bam done the alien reactor was
created much to Dr edgemer's claims
Quaid Molina and the rebels plans are
halted as everything is too perfect here
with kohagen foiling their plan too
perfect because it's all a dream
remember with cuado urging Quaid to
start the reactor free Mars edgemar's
claims of Quade becoming kohagen's bosom
buddy are also revealed to be true as he
and Hauser originally were working
together making Quaid like a double
agent upon himself Quaid and Molina
Escape rushing off to start the reactor
based off the visions showed him the
final run-in with Benny feels like all
of the other run-ins just poof he's
there but badass how Quaid kind of like
Gears of Wars Benny with the giant drill
I guess before the sensors this was way
more of a gruesome scene just stuff like
that just imagine now the Hologram
finally comes back into play with Quaid
using it against the Mars soldiers and
yes I know we all thought this wait a
minute aren't they shooting one another
in the crossfire and yes 100 True like
every time I've watched this this scene
bothers me but when Molina uses the
Hologram the soldiers do shoot one
another so I I guess just chalk it up as
plot convenience now thinking about it I
quote so many random lines from this
movie it had an imprint on me
specifically what Quaid says director as
his arms are severed off by the elevator
yeah just another scene that got the old
sensor treatment but honestly is still
hella brutal finally Quaid reaches the
switch to turn on the alien reactor and
this whole ending feels very
over-the-top action star movie One Last
Stand against the good guy versus the
evil guy ending which is purposely the
point because of the secret agent ego
trip dream specifically with what McLean
mentioned about getting the girl and
saving the day as Molina shows up just
in time they stop the explosion and the
reactor starts up but not before we get
even more horrifying practical puppets
of the three dying of explosive
decompression or I guess kohagen is the
only one to die here which is pretty on
the nose for a guy trying to deprive
people and control air this is a huge
ironic slap to the face for him the
ending shows the blue skies on Mars
Ernie had mentioned back at recall with
everyone in the Mars colony now
breathing the healthy clean air again a
Little Dream like to have this all
happen in a matter of what like 30
seconds but we do see Molina and Quade
standing without their spacesuits
similar to how the film opens the ending
once again has you questioned the
validity of whether or not this is a
dream I just did a terrible thought
what if this is a dream
well then kiss me quick before you wake
up and personally I'm still saying this
is a dream verhoven mentioned that the
fading to White is supposed to leave the
ending ambiguous and beg the question
but I consider this Quade being
lobotomized at recall and waking up a
couple of reasons obviously because
everything is of convenient nature
throughout all of this movie but the
bright light that fades in is up and to
the right almost in line with the
placement of an eye in a skull almost
looks like it originates from an eye
socket moving outward and lastly at this
moment and during the credits the
musical themes from when Quade
originally visits recall can be heard
implying that it was all a dream which
leads to Quade being lobotomized at the
end now this could all tie into a wild
Theory time about it being a Groundhog's
Day type of situation but but let's just
stick to this ending
[Music]
I always thought Total Recall was like a
cult hit 90s sci-fi movie that like no
one knew about but uh I was incredibly
wrong because not only was it
groundbreaking film at the time but
things started moving on this IP and
script as far back as the 70s Dan
O'Bannon and Ronald shoe set who worked
on the screenplay realized that it would
be far too expensive for the time just
casually went on to create alien in 1979
and then came back to this after it even
won an Academy Award for special
achievements in the academy for visual
effects for the time of which you know
later Toy Story got one as well in 1995.
surprisingly Total Recall had such an
impact that it spawned a handful of
comic books and video games but also a
late 1990s television prequel series
that unfortunately did not receive
favorable reviews instead leading more
into a Blade Runner kind of aesthetic
there were also early attempts to adapt
another Philip K dick novel into being a
sequel Minority Report which just did
not go through instead becoming the
Standalone Steven Spielberg and Tom
Cruise movie that we know and in 2012 a
reboot was made with Colin Farrell Kate
Beckinsale Jessica Beale and Brian
Cranston but just did not hit the mark I
mean it featured some cool zero g
shootouts but it just doesn't compare to
the original oh and yes yes I know
you're wondering the body count of this
film is 77. so uh the the more you know
anyway I'd be interested to see what
they did with a sequel or even spin-off
with this Tech in this world it's only a
matter of time before Hollywood Dives
back into this one but anyway I love
this 90s Schwarzenegger sci-fi gem but
let me know your thoughts below what are
your memories with Total Recall okay pun
intended memories but how do you think
it ends is it a dream is this reality
please let us know and I'll let you know
we're currently running a competition
giving away three copies of the rocky 4K
box set yeah on the 15th of March and
all you got to do to get a chance of
winning this is like this video
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment down below with your thoughts
of Total Recall we picked the comments
at random at the end of every single
month in the winners of last month are
on screen right now so if that's you
message me on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch
check out some of our other breakdowns
good stuff the unbreakable one is
fantastic but with all of that out of
the way thank you for your constant
support I've been Jared I'll see in the
next one take care and